si vite
vous qui êtes un grand confesseur devant
l'éternel vous arrive-t-il de vous
confesser n'ont jamais non enfin là
aussi j'ai pas dit mon dernier mot
mais c'est le cas de le dire on y va
venez vous confesser
fily vous vous présentez souvent comme
titi n'est à montmartre en fête est née
à coulommiers
vous avez honte de votre lieu de
naissance non mais comme je suis partie
de coulommiers alors j'avais six mois ça
m'a pas tellement influencée en revanche
j'ai passé toute mon enfance et toute
mon adolescence sur la butte montmartre
dont j'ai d'ailleurs comme vous pouvez
le constater gardé l'accent
vous avez une de vos origines sociales
non pas du tout d'ailleurs
elles sont modestes mais dit il c'est
quoi votre papa mon papa de directeur
d'une petite société
ma maman était l'opticienne vous avez
dit je me suis longtemps haye
il s'est passé quoi depuis je me suis
réconcilié avec coin parce que je
pouvais pas faire autrement mais c'est
vrai que j'aurais voulu être autrement
physiquement autrement
intellectuellement
d'être plus pure plus dur
et que à la longue on fini par dresser
le répertoire de tous ses défauts et que
dans le même temps les qualités si elles
existent vous apparaissent moins on peut
pas prendre en grippe quelqu'un avec qui
on est condamné à vivre jusqu'à la fin
et de surcroît quelqu'un qui vous
nourrit aussi bien les états de bastien
j'ai eu peur de grossir si j'ai vu que
je m'en accommode eh bien on je voudrais
pas devenir énorme mais c'est pas
mauvais d'être enveloppé quand on fait
un métier public s'inspire confiance à
la clientèle les effets de 105000
interview à peu près et celle que vous
avez préféré c'est celle de lanza del
vasto pourquoi prend parce que c'était
un philosophe qui avait mis en accord
sur harry sim c'est ses pensées ses
actes
c'est à dire qu'il prêchait le dénuement
et du vivait lui même dans une
communauté qu'il avait monté dans le sud
de la france et qui fonctionnait comme
aux premiers temps du monde veut dire
sans aucune des ressources du programme
ils filaient lui-même le lin dont il
fabriquait ses vêtements
c'est une espèce d'âge d'or et puis j'ai
vu grâce à lui quelque chose que je
n'avais jamais observée jusque là dans
la société française ou contemporaines
l'image d'un désintéressement complet
vous deviez mourir demain vous
regretteriez dans ma part vécu le pt
lonza le bateau de la vie non je pense
qu'il n'était pas fait pour moi j'en ai
deux ports digne d'autre part bon j'ai
eu une bonne petite existence de deux
journalistes multimédia qui m'a permis
d'avoir droit à une existence à laquelle
ne me destinais
nîmes aisée d'une libération ni mon
physique sur un certain plan j'ai quand
même l'impression d'avoir tiré le
maximum du minimum de votre fameux
emplois du temps vire est une classe
pour dieu il reste en filigrane de tout
ce que je fais le regret de ne pas avoir
eu la foi et leur gré ou six grands de
ne pas avoir rencontré des gens
susceptibles de me communiquer la leur
vous le regrettez oui